the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
in this session we're going to be
looking at carbohydrate biosynthesis
please look at storyboard 29 looking at
panel a the next set of pathways on
which we're going to focus concerns
carbohydrate biosynthesis first we're
going to look at the pathway by which
glycogen is made as you know glycogen is
the polymeric form of glucose that's
very readily available for energy
production the second pathway is
gluconeogenesis the organs that utilize
glucose as their metabolic fuel prefer
to have glucose at a concentration of
about 100 milligrams per deciliter in
the blood the challenge comes from the
fact that we eat only sporadically and
thus levels of glucose will go up and
down depending upon the time that has
passed since our last meal when glucose
levels drop gluconeogenesis is the
pathway that's activated it takes non
carbohydrate precursors converts them to
glucose and then secretes the glucose
into the blood ultimately to help
maintain a constant glucose
concentration looking at panel B our
first topic is the synthesis of glycogen
if you look back at my first two
lectures I described the structure of
glycogen which is also shown here the
piece of glycogen that I've shown
consists of a linear chain of glucose
molecules connected together through the
1 in 4 carbons chemically we call this
an alpha 1 4 linkage to the left of the
glycogen molecule is the non-reducing
end and to the right is the reducing end
which is connected by a tyrosine residue
to a protein called glycogenin
glycogenin is a variant of the glycogen
synthase enzyme we'll talk about later
glycogenin has the property that it can
synthesize a polymeric glucose chain
such as the one shown to boot up the
synthesis of glycogen in effect
glycogenin forms a primer molecule such
as the one shown that provides a
non-reducing end that can be extended by
its sister in
I'm glycogen synthase while I've drawn a
linear glucose I want you to keep in
mind that branches off of the six carbon
of the glucoses in the chain are
possible as I mentioned earlier glycogen
is designed for fast break down this
glucose units will quickly enter the
pathway of glycolysis and generate ATP s
in a matter of seconds
let's now look at panels see it's useful
to review the biochemical steps by which
glycogen is broken down because the
exact same intermediates appear in the
reverse order in the synthesis of
glycogen the key enzyme for glycogen
breakdown or glycogenolysis is glycogen
phosphorylase glycogen phosphorylase
progressively will nip off the
non-reducing end that is the leftmost
sugar as shown producing an oxonium ion
intermediate and as we saw in my first
lecture glycogen phosphorylase stereo
specifically adds inorganic phosphate to
the bottom phase that is the alpha phase
of the oxonium ion to give glucose
1-phosphate
with the stereochemistry shown once
again these same intermediates are going
to appear in the synthesis of glycogen
now let's take a look at the way that
glucose 1-phosphate interfaces with the
other biosynthetic and catabolic
pathways let's look at panel D this
metabolic map shows glycogen in the
lower right hand corner we can see how
glycogen alysus results in glycogen
breakdown to glucose 1-phosphate
and in the reverse direction we can see
how glucose 1-phosphate can be used to
make glycogen by way of two enzymes UDP
glucose pyro phosphorylase ugp and
glycogen synthase GS let's look a little
deeper at other pathways with which
glucose 1-phosphate
interfaces this schematic shows that
glucose 1-phosphate
can be converted to glucose 6-phosphate
by phosphoglucomutase PGM in this case
the phosphate is moved from the one
carbon to the sixths to the six carbon
of the glucose moiety the opposite
reaction also occurs that is if you have
glucose 6-phosphate phosphoglucomutase
will convert it to glucose 1-phosphate
glucose 6-phosphate is an intermediate
in glycolysis gluconeogenesis which is
the
next pathway we're going to look at and
another future pathway the pentose
phosphate pathway all of this shows us
that glucose 6-phosphate is a crossroads
and one of the branches that leads from
it and to it is by way of glucose
1-phosphate
let's imagine a scenario in which we eat
a meal glucose appears in the blood is
shown it is taken into the cell the
enzymes hexokinase or glucokinase will
phosphorylate the glucose into glucose
6-phosphate if the glucose is not needed
for glycolysis or the other pathways I
mentioned phosphoglucomutase will
convert the glucose 6-phosphate to
glucose 1-phosphate and then in the
pathway of glycogen synthesis glucose
1-phosphate will be polymerized into
glycogen for energy storage at this
point let's turn to storyboard 30 and
look at panel a now let's take a look at
the detailed pathway by which glucose
1-phosphate
is converted to glycogen at the left is
the structure of glucose 1-phosphate
the first enzyme involved is UDP glucose
pyro phosphorylase or ugp the second
substrate in this reaction is UTP
uridine triphosphate the UDP glucose
pyro phosphorylase catalyzes attack by
the phosphate on the 1 carbon of glucose
1-phosphate on the alpha phosphorus of
UTP the two products are pyrophosphate
and UDP glucose the reaction is made
thermodynamically irreversible by
hydrolysis of pyrophosphate by inorganic
pyro phosphatase into two molecules of
inorganic phosphate the UDP glucose is
the substrate for the next enzyme in the
sequence glycogen synthase I'm going to
divide the glycogen synthase reaction
into two parts in the first we see
cleavage of the bond between the 1
carbon of the glucose and the beta
phosphate of the UDP this reaction
liberate s' the UDP and generates the
oxonium ion shown in the brackets
structurally this oxonium ion is the
same intermediate we saw in glycogen
breakdown but here we're using it as a
biosynthetic reagent let's look at panel
B in this panel we continue the glycogen
synthase reaction in panel a
generated the oxonium ion of glucose
which is shown here in panel B in the
lower-left glycogen synthase activates
the hydroxyl group on the 4 carbon of
the terminal sugar residue that is the
sugar on the non-reducing end the oxygen
on the non reducing sugar residue of
glycogen then it taps the bottom of face
of the oxonium ion to give rise to a
glycogen unit that has been extended by
one glucose residue I have put an
asterisk on the six carbon of the
glucose residue that's been added to the
growing glycogen chain